yu kuizhi aujourd'hui bonne nouvelle on
se retrouve sur un show doha ça fait
longtemps n'est ce pas à pas sa peine
devrait être très dur à dire se
postionner ce nombre on apparaît donc
qu'au milieu d'une forêt voilà comme
dans 90% des jeux d'horreur avec une
pleine lune mais oui mais c'est parfait
caché par du brouillard voilà le
scénario classique on doit trouver une
sorte de manoirs je crois c'est tout ce
que j'ai lu sur le jeu c'est pas grand
chose c'est vrai ça son histoire sur
deux joueurs est juste un pont pour
faire genre qu'est une histoire un
ouvrier c'est juste jump scare james key
chez toi dessus et ça marche plus ou
moins c'est quoi il ya une sorte de
slender un moment c'est ça commentait ce
qu'on a peur là c'est parfois qu'on
demande avoir peur c'est un jeu
d'horreur la peur la peur ou est elle ou
ouais je m'en fais pas et des vieux
bruit quand même à howie une habitation
je peux pas y aller mais laisse moi bah
voila quand même s'il te plaît tu fais
cambrioler il déprime [ __ ] de merde là
j'avoue j'ai fait du mal au début de la
vidéo je regrette du vomi ah ben voilà
il ya un mec qui a fait un malaise donc
je propose qu'on le sauve à
photo efe la balançoire mais ça va il
n'y a pas trop de clichés dans le jeu
c'est ça qui est bien écoutez on va
sortir d'ici
1 on va aller à les tâches déjà voir si
l'homme qui fait son malaise et là-haut
allongé sur le parquet immobile mais
c'est un gros ls qui le fuit en a
partout où il a vomi partout baignoire
lavabo toilettes où tout est atteint est
déjà toi le fantôme tu arrêtes directeur
la balançoire ok je te mets un coup de
tête en plaques coup de tête de moins
visibles regardez y avait des fourmis
dans le puits annoncé des feuilles
pardon j'ai besoin de voir du vomi
partout que je propose qu'on prenne
cette tâche
pourquoi je pars 27h pourquoi peut
jamais prendre des armes [ __ ] j'ai
entendu des bruits de fougères peut-être
que le méchant est une fougère
je sais pas à quoi il ressemble donc
j'ai envie de le voir déjà oui tu
méfiant à lomé show bien quoi mais y'a
des to dance et fougères mais pas
réguler plus tard oui je sais pas
d'autorité par contre les fougères
l'agile autorité sur elle donc vous et
plus on moquait d'eux quand je m'énerve
y at il quelqu'un là dedans peut pas y
aller par derrière toujours une porte
par derrière comme ça pour pénétrer les
quatre ans dans le chapelle
regardez voilà vous avez vu j'ai
totalement tort salue sa canne azot
absence totale c'est un monstre
c'est un monstre ou pas je au il va ce
moment là la statue du mec ovronnaz où
elle aurait pu m'attaquer aussi faut
arrêter le délire là donc là on va avoir
le mec est comme ça qu'ils bougent pas
qu'ils passent et j'aime ça si tu me
quittes averses télé ça fait marrer j'en
ai marre là on est obligé de faire un
truc je pars la recherche d'un autre
chose pour game boy game jol donne moi
un jeu d'horreur other alors je prends
le premier cas l'air cool null null null
null null sauter factory tient aussi bob
sagot apprendre suis là voilà il ya du
sang partout ça doit être un jeu aura
les deux lots de ces parties où là c'est
quoi son annonce une image qui doit
donner envie de jouer au jeu ou [ __ ]
on va s'éclater e biodynamique games
production avec un nom comme ça
car jeu génial shrek qu'ils doivent
genest qui se life dieu en 2013 à et ben
voilà on sert trop donc j'étais bien je
dors alors [ __ ] quel bon choix
tout est vert déjà c'est un truc avec
shrek c'est sûr je m'amuse déjà plus que
sur l'autre je vois la 11e pas comme ça
mais à vous je ramasse des pommes une
voix celle qui me parle avec un bruit
deuxième peau mon gars qu'est ce que
c'est non c'est mal il a 17 ans mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans cette
[ __ ] de maison
donc c'est la forêt de shrek c'est ça il
est là regardez on voit son extrême gros
ventre mais qu'elle qualifie mais
quelles facs [ __ ] on peut le dire je
suis aussi venu buter attend le mec la
modéliser ce n'est pas facile à liberec
il est encore les bras comme ça quand
ils vous disent avec mais c'est
dégueulasse toge restée au pétard on a
quatre pommes on va voler toutes les
pommes tu peux pas nommer de cheval
jusqu'au pont en bois sont pas qui donc
préférence est possible on s'en bat les
couilles alors l'avantagent s'est vu
l'épaisseur de shrek qui peut pas le
rater quoi celle d'or il étouffe un
c'est un petit peu un bâton dont il est
un petit peu dur à repérer mais la
chaîne regardée coilbault énorme boule
verte qui arrive à l'horizon nous
volerons toutes les pommes shaikh aucune
d'entre elle ne pourra nous échapper m
mais c'était tu as envie de rester avec
les chansons et où elle écoule de
septembre et les coiffes voilà on peut
passer dans l'ombre pour certains
bonbons
à une grosse bombe au nom pouvait pas
mais ça vous le précisez dans les règles
sur la petite image là où ils mettent
les fesses de shrek fallait écrire ça va
très bien c'est quoi one way travers
s'étaient quittés le jeu comme satis que
l'année soit décédé même si on n'y va
pas comme ça je suis né énormément et si
jamais le srec dans les flammes morts il
est l'âme à regarder je vois une énorme
ventre arriver théron shrek shrek la
terreur shrek le bon j'arrive pas à toi
mon style est digne d'un film
alors vrai qu on nous prouve avec les
bras comme ça le long du corps
update est qu'il nous faut un coupable
de ce terrible incendie mais c'est pas
tout je travaillais comme l'âge la voix
ah non mais non mais c'est son robinet
de 20 la bombe tamedia ont fait enfermer
la 2e ou quoi écouter
tiens il a enfermé ces petits biscuits
qui était dedans y avait des biscuits je
l'entendais bon droit les wc il ya une
pomme c'est pas possible qu'il y ait des
wc métier pas de pomme voilà où j'en
étais sûr un mec qui fait un jeu de
cette qualité c'est sûr qu'il a des
idées bizarres 7 sur 8 mon gars wima
megabit partant faut pas se retourner
j'avais montré dans ce goût là si tu
veux toi ça bah non je suis pas une
rock-star maintenant je suis dans ton
band [ __ ] mais du coup dans tous ces
films qu'on a vu j'étais dans son ventre
par exemple là et là on était les
célébrités nous aussi mais ce qu'on leur
tente une toute dernière fois
voilà je comprendrai jamais pourquoi une
photo d'oignons sur cet écran mais bon
quoi ben ouais y'a plus de pommes dans
le trou bataille jeune aurier une
humiliation pour le titre du film
d'horreur et shrek shrek madness ça
sonne bien
cauchemar ya plus à manger dans le
manque de shrek dans cette forêt sans
déconner l'arrière garde d'élise à
bissau mort le sol il est mort là ni les
bords et un mur invisible mais [ __ ]
mes proches mais quoi mais vas-y oui
mais voilà lorsque japon 27,2 des vidéos
sur ces deux jeux d'horreur on sait bien
fois ils sont soit des jeux aujourd'hui
un et c'est de ma faute je sois cas
vidéo vous a plus ces cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo en cliquant sur votre
souris avec une pomme comme ça oui c'est
possible
merci à vous regarder on se retrouve
très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo tient
tout le monde pis
oui